change lives change organizations
organizations change the world when we
say change lives change organizations
and change the world we really mean it
Stanford GSB equips students to do that
you first have to start by changing
yourself students are naturally
encouraged innovative broadens your
perspectives on how to influence how to
lead I learn to be a critical analytical
thinker understand the global context of
management at the GSB I can move
virtually the whole world while studying
at this place I have access to a lot of
leaders of international organizations
people who start their own companies
film directors bankers and private
equity consultant renowned leaders from
around the world labelled prize winner
it's really a transformational
experience change lives change
organizations change the work I just
came back from the Stanford single eye
exam program sizzle in Kenya new one
live when the faculty come on these
trips we can bring that experience
directly into the classroom it's been
inspiring complicated exciting you might
hit a pencil a meeting with
Mankato
we're meeting with Charlotte screaming
coffee in China President Kagame the
person who won that dynamite boiler
former best
and the Minister of Industry and
Commerce and lessons learned from GSP
lungs were amazing see how nice a very
warm hearted to give us a richer Korea
device we have a group of alumni who
have had incredible impeccable
individuals who have lived on mantra
change lives change organizations change
the world hopefully change all three but
I'm really interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation energy a
clean tech space we working in tourism
improve private equity combining
business benefit Stanford GSB believes
in the individual's ability to affect
change make the difference in the lives
of you know hundreds millions of
people's pursue your dream dream on a
world scale change lives change
organizations and change the world